[Musique]
merci
[Applaudissements]
merci à tous d'abord maintenant vous
savez vous savez pourquoi est ce que
j'ai voulu françois-xavier bellamy
[Applaudissements]
et vous savez aussi pourquoi est ce que
pour nous quand rencontre après
rencontre un peu partout en france on
rentre dans ses salons on se retrouve
il ya quelque chose qui se passe ça
faisait longtemps trop longtemps qu'on
n'avait pas ressenti cette envie cet
enthousiasme cette émotion de partager
ensemble une vision tout à la fois pour
notre pays et pour l'europe
je vous avais promis que ensemble nous
ferions tout pour rebâtir
ferions tout pour retrouver ce qu'est la
vocation d'une nouvelle droite dans
notre pays je vous avais promis que nous
ferions tout pour retrouver la dignité
des valeurs que nous portons et bien
nous sommes à ce rendez vous et quand je
rentre dans cette salle comme je vous
vois tout ce qu'ils avaient répondu
présents qui est là je sais qu'il ya
dans cette campagne
une seule liste qui a une dynamique une
seule liste où il se passe quelque chose
une seule liste qui semaine après
semaine progresse c'est la nôtre c'est
celle des républicains c'est celle de
l'union de la droite et du centre
et vous pouvez en être fier parce que
c'est chez nous qu'il ya quelque chose
qui se passe dans cette campagne des
européennes
[Applaudissements]
je sais que vous êtes là
je voudrais rendre hommage un certain
nombre de personnalités qui sont là
aussi
et je voudrais leur rendre hommage parce
qu'elle incarne ce que je me suis
employé à faire retrouver le
rassemblement de notre famille politique
je voudrais d'ailleurs d'abord et très
solennellement rendre hommage à son
claude remercier jean-claude de nous
accueillir dans cette ville de marseille
à laquelle jean claude tu as consacré
toute ta me remercier jean-claude parce
que c'est lui je ne l'oublient pas qui a
contribué à porter sur les fonts
baptismaux l'union de notre famille
politique quand tu as fais partie de
ceux qui ont été les pères fondateurs de
l'ump et remercier enfin jean-claude
parce que j'ai toujours pu compter sur
ton soutien
j'ai toujours pu compter sur ta loyauté
et c'est toujours respecté son ancrage
ce sont des valeurs soit disant que le
nouveau monde méprise et bien moi ce
sont les valeurs que j'estime la loyauté
l'ancrage le travail sur la durée
merci à toi jean claude merci
et je veux saluer tous les élus qui sont
présents ici et qui incarne ce
rassemblement que je souhaite que nous
puissions édifier et fortifiée au fur et
à mesure je veux remercier bruno de
veiller sur notre fédération comme il le
fait avec l' enthousiasme et la jeunesse
quasi éternelle qui est la sienne
je veux remercier martin qui déploie une
énergie extraordinaire dans notre
département et dans cette métropole
quel édifice dans le prolongement de ce
qui a été fait bravo martine et j'aime
ton caractère et je veux remercier
renault mon voisin du sud qui est dit
fiennes meerab le mans et qui porte
cette voie de la région sud qui l'a
rebaptisé merci renaud de ta flamme et
ton énergie merci renaud mes amis dans
cette élection il voulait décider à
votre place et il s'était déjà réparti
les rôles
les français ne devait avoir que deux
choix soit d'un côté marine le pen soit
de l'autre côté emmanuel macron et si
notre liste petit à petit progresse
c'est précisément parce que je suis
convaincu que les français attendent
autre chose
les français sont un peuple qui n'aiment
pas être emprisonnés les français sont
un peuple qui n'accepte pas qu'on leur
décrète le résultat des urnes avant
qu'il se soit eux-mêmes prononcer les
français ne veulent pas être prisonnier
de la réédition de ce second tour de la
présidentielle où il n'aurait le choix
contre le chaos de marine le pen est la
déception des manuels macron pourquoi
est ce que notre liste progresse parce
que nous nous leur apportons une autre
alternative est un autre choix
et au fond dans cette europe
l'un comme l'autre qui se font
d'ailleurs la courte échelle incarne
tous les deux une impasse la passe de
marine le pen c'est l'impasse de la
déconstruction de l'europe ce que
propose marine le pen c'est la
déconstruction de l'europe c'est
l'abandon de l'euro mais enfin il suffit
de regarder ce qui se passe de l'autre
côté de la manche
pourquoi
rendre que ce choix serait
catastrophique pour la france
catastrophique comment ne peut-elle pas
comprendre que nous avons besoin de
l'europe plus que jamais face à la chine
face aux états unis face aux défis de
l'immigration face aux dérèglements
climatiques
je combats de tout en énergie dans cette
campagne marine le pen parce que je suis
convaincu que ce qu'elle propose pour la
france ce serait une sortie de
l'histoire le choix le plus dramatique
depuis la seconde guerre mondiale celui
de sortir de l'europe
je ne veux pas de ce destin pour nos
enfants et la deuxième proposition celle
d' emmanuel macron est tout autant une
impasse ce qu'ils proposent c'est
toujours plus de l'europe qui ne marche
plus plus de bureaucratie
lui qui a proposé au moins une quinzaine
d' autorité administrative
supplémentaire toujours plus d'impôts
lui qui a proposé 5 impôt européen
supplémentaire est toujours plus
d'élargissement lui qui se prononcent
pour l'entrée des balkans à l'intérieur
de l'union européenne et l'adhésion dans
les délais les plus courts de la
roumanie et de la bulgarie à l'intérieur
de schengen les deux sont des impasses
les deux danses au dessus du volcan en
se faisant l'un et l'autre la courte
échelle et en jouant avec l'avenir de
notre démocratie en se répartissant les
rôles à lui le populiste à elle le
progressiste ou en sens inverse à elle
le populiste et à lui le progressiste
ils veulent faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait
pas d'autres voies dans la démocratie
française
eh bien nous nous sommes là pour faire
en sorte que les français aient le choix
parce que j'ai toujours cru qu'en
politique on avait le choix parce que
j'ai toujours cru qu'on ne dictait pas
aux français ce qu'ils avaient le droit
de penser et ce qu'ils n'avaient pas le
droit de dire
[Applaudissements]
refonder l'europe et pour cela nous
avons essayé ensemble de pouvoir vous
proposer ce trio je suis fier de ce que
fait françois xavier
parce que françois-xavier rawdon de la
vision parce qu'il retire la politique
vers le haut elle qui se délabre jour
après jour je ne sais pas si vous avez
fait attention lors de ce débat de
france 2 où il y avait les différentes
têtes de liste des listes européennes
on leur avait demandé à chacun de venir
avec un objet qui devait incarner ce
qu'il voulait faire pour l'europe
la tête de liste du rassemblement
national avait choisi une passoire rouge
une tête de liste dans un connaît même
plus le nom avait pris une paire de
menottes sur laquelle il avait mis des
autocollants jaunes et je me disais au
fur et à mesure que chaque tête de liste
sortait ses objets mais comment la
politique at elle pu devenir cela
cette politique qui en france à une
époque était incarné aussi bien par
pierre mendès-france que par le général
de gaulle et la tête de liste dans
marche
elle avait sorti une petite boîte de
piment d'espelette j'adore le piment
d'espelette mais enfin quand on parle
d'europe peut-être y at-il autre chose à
dire et françois-xavier bellamy lui as a
sorti un livre et qu'elle livre l'iliade
d'homère et je me suis dit voilà quelqu
un au moins qui nous rend notre dignité
et qui redonne du sens à ce qu'est la
politique
il a à ses côtés arnaud danjean
j'aimerais bien qu'arnaud se lève pour
que vous le voyez c'est un des meilleurs
spécialistes de toutes les questions de
sécurité de défense et de lutte contre
le terrorisme
il a à ses côtés agnès il a à ses côtés
patrick qui a fait le redressement de la
ciotat ce port admirable qui avaient
connu cette dure épreuve de la
sinistrose industrielle et qui a refusé
baisser les bras et qui en a fait
aujourd'hui une des plus belles
réussites françaises de renaissance
merci patrick je suis fier de ce que tu
as fait et il a à ses côtés sa robe il
vous a parlé avec l'émotion qui était la
sienne
y compris de ce que représentait pour
elle qui venait d'une famille venue de
l'autre côté de la méditerranée et qui a
beaucoup versé son sang pour la défense
de la france sans rien demander en
retour et en étant souvent bull est à
l'image de bien de ces familles harkis
qui ont versé leur sang pour la france
et qui ont été oubliées dans le destin
de la république
sarah je suis fier que tu sois sur notre
liste c'est le narcisse notre histoire
que tu pas parler de l'europe
nous nous parlons de l'europe
les autres parlent de la commission
européenne les autres parlent de
bruxelles les autres parlent de l'union
européenne nous nous parlons de l'europe
l'europe c'est tout autre chose
l'europe c'est une âme l'europe ça n'est
pas juste l'addition de service et de
subventions l'europe c'est un projet
quand les pères fondateurs ont choisi ce
drapeau on est au lendemain de la
seconde guerre mondiale l'europe a été
détruite par la barbarie nazie et par la
violence de la seconde guerre mondiale
tout est à terre et ils choisissent de
mettre sur ce drapeau quoi les étoiles
de la couronne de la vierge quand ils
font cela ils font un projet de
civilisation
ils font évidemment un projet de
ce qu'il refuse c'est quoi ce qu'il
refuse c'est que la voix de l'europe et
son destin dans l'histoire s'arrête ce
qu'il refuse c'est cette idée que
l'europe soit maintenant
le sous traitant des états unis et que
nous n'ayons plus notre mot à dire
ils font un projet de civilisation
pourquoi est-ce que vous êtes là les uns
les autres parce que au fond la question
que nous nous posons est exactement la
même est ce que nous acceptons que
l'europe sorte de l'histoire est ce que
nous acceptons de renoncer petit à petit
à notre mode de vie
silencieusement ou est-ce qu'au
contraire nous voulons nous battre pour
faire en sorte de redonner un souffle à
cette europe que nous aimons à ce mode
de vie qui est le nôtre à cette culture
qui est la nôtre et que nous chérissons
pourquoi est ce que nous avons inscrit
cette devise pour porter ce combat dans
les européennes
parce que nous l'europe que nous voulons
c'est l'europe de la civilisation
l'europe que nous voulons c'est celle
qui marchait l'europe que nous voulons
c'est l'europe des projets l'europe que
nous voulons c'est celle qui imposait sa
voix dans le monde parce qu'elle sait
qui est laid l'europe que nous voulons
c'est l'europe puissance si on vous
demande l'europe que vous voulez
répondez l'europe que nous voulons c'est
l'europe de la civilisation
c'est pour cela que je vous demande de
vous battre et de vous engager
[Applaudissements]
une civilisation qu'est ce que c'est
qu'une civilisation
eh bien d'abord une civilisation ce sont
des frontières oui des frontières quand
romulus et rémus trace le pourtour de
rome il trace avec un sillon la limite
de la cité parce que ceux qui veulent
signifier à tous ceux qui viendront
c'est que ce sont eux qui décideront qui
a le droit d'entrée et qui n'a pas le
droit d'entrer à l'intérieur de rome
comment avons nous pu oublier cela
l'europe ne peut pas être sans limites
il faut qu'il y ait des limites l'europe
ne peut pas s'étendre sans fin on ne
peut pas poursuivre cet élargissement
qui petit à petit en faisant rentrer
sans cesse des pays nouveaux et
différents abouti à affaiblir de
l'intérieur l'union européenne la
différence majeure que nous portons face
à emmanuel macron dans cette liste des
européennes c'est que nous tous ceux qui
sont sur notre liste ont pris un
engagement très clair ils voteront
pendant la durée de leur mandat contre
toute décision qui aboutirait à faire
des élargissements supplémentaires
contre tout élargissement
supplémentaires et nous en aurons
d'autant plus besoin que le président de
la république a comme par hasard
accepter que les négociations sur
l'entrée de l'albanie
j'ai bien dit l'albanie commence en juin
de cette année juste après les élections
européennes
comme par hasard eh bien ce sera un
sujet majeur de différence pour cette
campagne nous nous sommes clairs
l'albanie ne rentre pas dans l'union
européenne pendant la totalité du mans
bat de nos députés européens bien sûr
et j'en profite pour dire qu'avec nos
partenaires de la cdu ou nous porterons
le même engagement
il faut cesser les négociations avec la
turquie la turquie n'est pas européenne
elle ne rentre pas dans l'union
européenne et en arrête de faire
semblant de discuter des frontières que
l'on connaît et des frontières que l'on
défend françois xavier vous a très bien
expliqué ce que nous proposons qui est
une double protection de nos frontières
une protection européenne et une
protection national marine le pen fait
une erreur
elle déteste tellement l'europe qu'elle
la recette même quand l'europe est une
protection pour la france évidemment
qu'il faut l'europe à la frontière
grecque à la frontière espagnole à la
frontière italienne
parce que sinon n'a pas l'europe tous
ceux qui rentrent par la grèce l'italie
et l'espagne finissent par arriver dans
notre pays
pousser parfois par la fol générosité
d'un système de solidarité que nous
offrons à tort à des gens qui n'ont
parfois même pas cotisé une heure de
travail
en arrivant sur le sol français ce qui
n'est pas raisonnable mais surtout
quelle est notre responsabilité parce
que nous ne devons pas sous-estimer les
drames qui ont lieu dans la méditerranée
ne devons pas sous-estimer les
souffrances qui amène parfois toute
cette jeunesse a quitté leur pays pour
arriver chez nous ensuite hagard en
tétant déracinés est-ce qu'on leur offre
un avenir
on ne leur offre pas un avenir ce qu'est
notre vraie responsabilité ce qu'est la
vraie générosité
celle dont parlait peggy par la fausse
naïveté qui aboutit à la fausse
générosité mais la fermeté qui permet la
vraie générosité la vraie générosité
c'est celle qui consiste à se battre
pour que l'avenir soit en afrique
la vraie générosité celle qui consiste à
se battre pour développer l'afrique
la vraie générosité et celle qui
consiste à se battre pour dire que
l'avenir de la jeunesse africaine est en
afrique mais qu'il n'est pas en europe
parce que nos capacités d'intégration
dépassés il faut se battre pour dire aux
pays africains nous vous aiderons à vous
développer
mais il ya une contrepartie vous devez
prendre vous devez reprendre les
ressortissants qui sont arrivés en
europe et qui n'ont rien à faire en
europe et qui n'ont pas respecté les
règles qui sont les nôtres et pour qu'il
y ait une civilisation ensuite il faut
des projets communs il faut des choses
comportant comme un conte série qu'on
fait avancer petit à petit pas les
normes
ces normes que détestait tocqueville qui
finissent par énerver et bt qui
décourage tout ce qu'ils entreprennent
dans notre pays n'importe quels élus
locaux qui essaient de monter un projet
n'importe quel agriculteur n'importe
quel artisan n'importe quel commerçant
n'importe quel entrepreneur l'europe des
normes mais aussi la france parce que
chez nous nous sommes si intelligent
hervé que nous n'avons de cesse que de
rajouter des normes aux normes et tu
l'as si bien dit et je te remercie de
porter ce bon sens comme tu le fais à
l'intérieur de notre liste et je
voudrais vous demander vraiment de
rendre hommage à hervé parce que hervé
nous a montré un chemin qui est très
important le centre en france ça n'est
pas un non lieu
le centre en france est un centre qui
avait toujours été fidèle à la vocation
du centre droit le choix très fort qui
servait c'est de montrer que dans le
même temps on reconstruit une droite
pierre clerc qui ne baisse pas du regard
cette droite là est capable de rayonner
et de rassembler et de reconstruire
l'union de la droite et du centre qui
nous a toujours permis de gagner et les
germes que nous posons aujourd'hui nous
emmènera jusqu'en 2022 hervé et nous le
porterons ensemble ces projets mais il y
en a tant moins de capacité de normes
pour la commission plus de capacité de
projets pourquoi la commission
européenne ne peut pas appel plus
investir pour aider nos ports à se
développer
pourquoi la commission européenne ne
peut-elle pas porter de grandes
infrastructures ferroviaires pour sortir
les camions de nos autoroutes
ces camions parfois polonais lituaniens
romain qui inondent nos autoroutes et
dont on se dit mais comment ont-ils pu
jusque là et qu'on puisse les mettre sur
des cas sur des chemins de fer pour
éviter qu'ils polluent et qu'il rendre
nos autoroutes et nos voies de
circulation si compliqué couvrir la
totalité de notre territoire en 5 j en
internet très haut débit ça ce sera un
beau projet pour l'europe et je rêve
d'une europe qui soit capable de fédérer
tous les laboratoires de recherche pour
travailler ensemble sur le défi du
xxième siècle les maladies
neurodégénératives la maladie
d'alzheimer celle qui représente un
drame pour bien des familles et qui
aboutit à ce que petit à petit jour
après jour on perd le contact avec
l'être cher avec lequel on avait tous
partagé et qu'au fur et à mesure que la
fin approche
on perd aussi les moyens de la
communication habituelle et qu'il ne
reste plus à l'arrivée que le regard
toutes les familles qui ont été marqués
par alzheimer le savent c'est une
épreuve qui est terrible une épreuve
psychologique une épreuve physique
une épreuve aussi dans cette façon de
faire le deuil qui est si difficile
comme je rêverais que nous puissions
nous doter comme nous le proposons d'une
grande cause européenne pour les cinq
ans qui viennent et que l'europe puisse
revenir dans cinq ans avec fierté en
disant nous sommes le continent qui a
permis de trouver les réponses aux
maladies neurodégénératives et à la
maladie d'alzheimer cette europe là
c'est celle que j'aime cette europe là
c'est celle que je chérissais quand
j'étais étudiant c'est l'europe des
projets c'est l'europe qui nous rend
fiers c'est l'europe qui permet d'aller
de l'avant
c'est l'europe qui est capable de défier
tout à la fois les états unis la chine
tout en oeuvrant sur l'amélioration de
la vie quotidienne de nos compatriotes
oui c'est cette europe que je veux que
nous retrouvions
et enfin une civilisation c'est une
culture c'est une histoire c'est un
patrimoine
cette culture cette histoire ce
patrimoine dont pâle françois xavier
ils sont aujourd'hui menacés ils sont
menacés
c'est sans doute le plus dur pour nous
par des gens qui sont nés sur le sol
français sur le continent européen
par des gens auxquels l'europe et la
france ont tout donné qui ont bénéficié
de toute notre générosité et qui ont
pourtant tourner leur haine et leur arme
contre se payer ce continent qui les a
abrité et protégé
la question de l'islamisme est une
question majeure
j'ai bien dit de l'islamisme que je ne
confonds pas avec la question bien
évidemment de l'islam parce que les
victimes de l'islamisme sont les
français qui tombent les victimes de
l'islamisme sont ceux qui ont une autre
religion les victimes de l'islamisme
sont aussi les musulmans modérés qui
subissent parfois le joue dans les
quartiers de ces islam intégriste qui
dénature la religion musulmane
ça c'est la vérité eh bien il faut
combattre cet islamisme il faut le
combattre de toutes nos forces il faut
cesser d'être naïfs
quand la france la république patrick
elle courage de mettre en place la
laïcité
elle a demandé à l'église catholique
bien des efforts pour mettre en place
ces lumières et cet équilibre sur lequel
s'est construit ensuite la république et
l'église catholique c'est adopter s'est
adapté comment pouvons-nous faire preuve
de tant de naïveté face à cet islamisme
il faut qu'il y ait des mesures qui sont
fermes
ce que nous proposons c'est un pacte
contre l'islamisme à l'échelle de
l'europe qui d'abord repose sur trois
principes simples le premier les
mosquées salafistes doivent être fermés
en europe toutes les mosquées salafistes
doivent être fermés en europe
la deuxième chose quand il y à des imams
qui prêchent la haine comme il y en a
encore en ce moment même à toulouse où
un imam qui a appelé au meurtre contre
les juifs continuent à pouvoir préfet
vendredi après vendredi un imams qui
prêchent la haine doit quitter l'europe
et doit quitter la france
on doit pas accepter qu'ils puissent
continuer à prêcher la haine et enfin
sur la question du jihad
je suis allé en irak je suis allé à
mossoul
je suis allé voir ce qu'était la
barbarie jihadistes j'ai vu au coeur de
mossoul
ce terrain de foot sur lequel on faisait
jouer des gamins de 10 ans avec les
têtes décapitées de ceux qui avaient été
tués par la barbarie d'âge
j'ai échangé avec ces familles zidi qui
ont été des esclaves sexuelles des
djihadistes qui se les revendait d'un
djihadiste un autre et qui étaient
violées à chaque fois en ayant éprouvé
les pires souffrances qu'une femme
puisse endurer
j'ai vu la destruction j'ai vu les
familles qui ont été anéantis
comment peut-on accepter envisager une
seule seconde que ceux qui sont partis
là bas et fait cela puisse ensuite
revenir sur le sol français et sur le
continent européen
comment peut-on envisager cela le
président de la république a d'ores et
déjà accepté que 200 djihadistes
reviennent en france
eh bien nous nous portons et bien nous
nous portons une demande qui est très
clair que l'europe organise un tribunal
international qui soit et se tiennent en
irak que ce tribunal international
permettent de juger les djihadistes qui
ont commis leur crime en irak et en
syrie
et qu'une fois jugés et condamnés ils
restent en irak et en syrie parce qu'ils
n'ont plus
à mettre un pied sur le continent
européen mes amis nous sommes une
civilisation extraordinaire qui est le
fruit de ces trois racines dont françois
xavier a parlé ici vous êtes à marseille
cette ville extraordinaire qui a su
intégrer des familles qui venaient de
partout des familles qui venaient
d'italie des familles qui venaient
d'espagne des familles qui venaient du
portugal des familles qui venaient
d'arménie les familles qui venaient de
pau line des pays de l'est
des familles qui venaient du sud de
tunisie d'algérie du maroc des familles
qui sont venus chez nous à l'image de
cet ouvrier avec lequel j'ai adoré
changé à la ciotat et qui travaillait
sur les plus beaux vaisseau du monde
avec fierté et que j'ai interrogé sur
son itinéraire et qui m'a dit je suis
venu ici tout gamin avec mon père je
venais de tunisie et mon père nous
disait attention à compter de ce jour tu
te tiens bien tu travailles dur à
l'école tu écoute ce que tes maîtres de
10 à compter de ce jour ton pays c'est
la france à compter de ce jour je veux
que tu sois plus français que les
français
ça c'était l'histoire de l'intégration
française et qu'avons nous fait mes amis
comment en sommes nous arrivés là et
bien petit à petit nous avons inversé le
devoir d'intégration
nous avons eu un président de la
république qui pendant la campagne
électorale expliqué qu'il n'y avait pas
une culture française nous avons un
président de la république qui est allé
de l'autre côté de la méditerranée en
algérie pour aller glaner je ne sais
quelle voie en expliquant que la france
n'aurait commis tout au long de son
histoire que des crimes contre
l'humanité en algérie insultant cela la
mémoire de bien des familles qui avaient
oeuvré en algérie
nous avons inversé le devoir
d'intégration nous avons oublié que pour
accueillir il faut d'abord transmettre
nous avons oublié d'enseigner à ceux qui
viennent chez nous qu'ils doivent chérir
notre histoire et notre culture
oui il y à une leçon à notre dame la
leçon de l' incendie de notre dame c'est
qu'il ya des incendies visibles les
incendies dans lesquelles on voit un
bâtiment partir dans lequel on a le
coeur serré parce qu'on a l'impression
que c'est une partie de notre histoire
qui perd les prenez garde
il ya aussi des incendies invisible
à chaque fois qu'on renonce d'enseigner
l'histoire de france parce que dans la
salle de classe quelqu'un explique que
ça n'est pas compatible avec sa religion
c'est un incendie invisible à chaque
fois à chaque fois qu'une femme n'a plus
le droit de choisir comment est ce
qu'elle se vêtit parce que quelques
intégristes lui dicte son comportement
7 un incendie invisible à chaque fois
que dans un hôpital un médecin homme ne
peut pas intervenir sur une patiente
femme parce que son mari explique que ça
n'est pas compatible avec sa religion
7 un incendie invisible mes amis
pourquoi est-ce que je n'ai jamais voulu
lâcher sur la question des crèches
ce tout petit symbole parce que je pense
qu'à chaque fois que l'on recule on
oublie ce que nous sommes
les crèches est un petit symbole de ce
que nous sommes un petit symbole de ses
racines chrétiennes que nous voulons
voir inscrite à nouveau dans les traités
fondateurs de l'union européenne
je ne veux plus que nous reculions
souvenons nous mes amis de cette règle
qui était cette règle si simple rappelé
par saint-augustin à rome fais comme les
romains et bien retrouvons ce qui est la
règle de l'intégration celle qui nous a
toujours permis d'avancer ensemble
c'est à celui qui arrive dans notre pays
de s'adapter et ça n'est pas à notre
pays de s'adapter à celui qui vient dans
notre pays
mes amis je veux que vous retrouviez
cette fierté
nous sommes ici à marseille
au nom de quoi aurions-nous honte de ce
qu'est l'histoire de notre pays
marseille est un des emblèmes de ce
qu'est l'histoire de france doyenne de
toutes les cités françaises
fondée par les grecs magnifié par l'
empire romain qui en a fait un de ses
joyaux et qui disait seul marseille a su
conjuguer à la fois la culture grecque
et la culture romaine christianisé par
saint victor avec ce symbole merveilleux
de notre dame de la garde
comme ce symbole merveilleux de notre
dame du puy en velay qui veille sur nos
deux sites et avec la même attention
cette cité merveilleuse qui a été
capable de partir à l'assaut du monde
dont les marseillais ont contribué à
l'histoire magnifique de cette france
qui s'est projeté au-delà d'elle-même
cette cité qui a su tout à la fois
inspiré monte cristo et pagnol sept
sites extraordinaires qui a été la terre
de la révolution cette cité qui a
défendu les lumières la croyance dans le
progrès et cette cité qui tentent en
étant fière de son histoire se projette
de façon extraordinaire dans une
modernité qui force le respect cette
cité qui est la capitale d'euromed cette
cité qui assure édifier son port cette
cité qui pierre après pierre puise dans
ce passé merveilleux qui fait de cette
ville une ville à nulle autre comparable
une ville qui incarne aussi la capacité
de la france à retrouver son avenir
c'est cela l'europe c'est cela la france
c'est une capacité à s'asseoir sur des
racines parce qu'ici dès qu'on gratte un
peu la terre on trouve les fondations de
tous ceux qui nous ont précédés et bien
c'est cela que moi j'aime c'est une
histoire dont nous pouvons à la fois
être fiers et dont nous devons être
digne c'est cela notre combat dans cette
campagne des européennes
refonder l'europe et rétablir la france
nous avons vingt jours vingt jours pour
convaincre 20 jours pour transformer cet
espoir 20 jours pour faire en sorte que
le mouvement qui ai commencé à se
dresser avance les autres veulent battre
le rassemblement national
le rassemblement national veut battre en
main
nous vous proposons un tout autre défi
je n'en connais pas de plus beau en
politique
retrouvez notre identité redonner un
souffle à notre avenir
vive l'europe et vive la france
[Applaudissements]